crisis what crisis
it may look overcast today but the Sun
always shines for this man Klaus strike
nur has a device on his roof that
manages to coax thermal energy out of
the cloudiest of skies this is not your
standard black photovoltaic plate these
tubes are solar thermal collectors with
a difference
they consist of evacuated glass tubes
with a copper plate inside coated with
titanium nitride oxide through that goes
a thin pipe carrying a liquid that heats
up extremely quickly retiree strike nur
set up the system three years ago he
used to heat with gas before he got the
solar bug first of all to save money gas
is expensive and the price will probably
continue to rise second for the
environment and at some point the gas is
going to run out glass man and this is
the man who's turning the innovative
tubes into a marketable success Reinhold
Weiser was a solar pioneer back in the
1980s eight years ago he and a team of
partners from the light tube industry in
eastern Germany took the principle of
solar thermal energy a step further
compared with photovoltaics or
harvesting electricity from the Sun this
sector did not look as likely to get off
the ground there was a phase when
photovoltaic energy got substantial
funding which helped to create a market
for it well they have to say that solar
thermal energy did not enjoy the same
treatment as without some usual news
program solar thermal energy was
bedeviled by the problems involved in
fitting the tubes visor has since
developed highly practical plug in parts
as a result the vacuum tube collectors
can be aligned at optimal angles to the
Sun to produce heat in the greatest and
coldest of weather
they have very low outside temperatures
in Canada we have the facility over
there where the temperatures can drop to
minus 50 degrees Celsius in the winter
but it's still able to generate high
carrier temperatures the solution the
tube within a tube the construction
enables the heat to be transferred with
a minimum of loss thanks to the high
vacuum another innovation from visors
company the boss himself demonstrates
how the tube clicks into place and can
be rotated 360 degrees it's all made in
Germany and most of it is simple by hand
the anger Munda based firm in the
northeast of the country might still
have that operating out of a garage look
but demand from overseas is growing the
message is spreading in cold regions
solar heating may be more important than
electricity storm causing power grid
renewable energy legislation wind
turbines funding for photovoltaic plants
these are all issues in the public eye
but there are only 30 percent of the
full picture if we want to take
renewables seriously we need to consider
the other 70% ohan cool I'm finding the
truth is that thermal energy has been
treated like a poor relation by the
government team availability from a
tundish patented from a witness Wiggio
visors tubes undergo substantial testing
the components come with a 20 year
guarantee come rain or storm this solar
innovator is clearly counting on a
bright future